thème du jour élus de la marne c'est ce
dont le groupe l'est républicain bonjour
1 et paul savary jours merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous on va commencer par le
coronavirus 1 avant de voir ce qui s'est
passé hier au sénat une question vous
qui êtes médecin est ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter ce camp un virus jeudi
rassurant la population faut pas
s'inquiéter mais il faut prendre des
précautions il véritablement à avoir un
comportement individuel et comprend un
peu avec les habitudes ne passent les
deux passes et serré les mains se laver
régulièrement les mains pas forcément
souhaitée au coût des enfants etc
donc c'est vrai que il ya quelques liens
affectifs qu'il faut un peu rompre
pendant ce temps là et c'est en faisant
en sorte de prendre ces mesures que
l'épidémie ne se propagera en tout cas
moins vite mais quoi quand une épidémie
virale à auxerre on va arriver on n'est
pas encore au stade de l'épidémie on est
allé endémie je pense mais mais ça va
forcément tournés vers l'épidémie vu le
contexte international et bien
effectivement il ya des mesures à
prendre sur le plan national passé un
stade iii veut dire un certain nombre de
dispositions selon les territoires selon
les endroits où il ya des foyers
et puis des mesures individuelles où il
faut et que dans la mesure du possible
éviter certains déplacements certains
contacts pas forcément aller voir ces
personnes âgées à la maison de retraite
etc
donc il faut véritablement que nos
concitoyens n'ont pas si inquiète mais
prennent des précautions pour savoir si
la france est prête à faire face à cette
épidémie on va en parler avec notre
journaliste il jourdain
[Musique]
bonjour yann dont je revenais pas
festina qui poursuit donc sa
mobilisation autour du coronavirus on le
disait hier un débat organisé sur ce
thème dans l'hémicycle un débat sur les
mesures prises par le gouvernement pour
limiter les risques de propagation ce
débat il a été demandé par la commission
des affaires sociales objectif pédagogie
apaisement d'un climat que certains
sénateurs 1 considère comme anxiogène on
l'aura compris pas de place à la
polémique dans l'hémicycle alors que
quatre personnes sont décédées en france
alors commencer rouler ses débuts
comment s'est déroulé ce débat c'est en
plusieurs temps selon l'ordre des prises
de parole d'abord le gouvernement puis
les groupes politiques et puis enfin une
séance de questions-réponses ligue et
veyran est venu au sénat avec un mot
d'ordre la transparence le ministre de
la santé qui a aussi rendu hommage aux
professionnels de santé écouter
et si c'est par gros temps que l'on
reconnaît les bons marins je peux vous
assurer que tous les professionnels de
santé que j'ai rencontré ces derniers
jours m'ont impressionné par leur
réactivité leur sang froid et leur sens
du devoir
voilà pour olivier ferrand le stade iii
de l'épidémie n'est pas encore atteint
le stade iii oriane c'est lorsque le
virus est répandu sur l'ensemble du
territoire et qu'il n'est plus possible
d'identifier les chaînes de
contamination est justement est ce que
les sénateurs ont été rassurés par les
propos du ils ont en tout cas été
rassurant alain milon a rappelé que la
grippe saisonnière faisait elle aussi
des milliers de morts chaque année en
france
il faut selon le président de la
commission des affaires sociales lutter
contre l'effet que nous les fausses
nouvelles et remettre de la rationalité
dans le débat public sur ce thème
certains sénateurs ont néanmoins eu un
message plus politique et ont réclamé
plus de moyens pour l'hôpital public
c'est le cas notamment de la communiste
laurence cohen écouter comme madame
busin vous semble aimer le jeu de
bonneteau puisque vous annoncez
débloquer 260 millions d'êtres pour les
hôpitaux
mais détail important ce soutien
financier sera pris sur les réserves de
l'exercice budgétaire 2010 9 n'ont
dépensé autrement dit sur le budget de
l'hôpital lui-même belle entreprise de
qom n'est pas de volonté réelle de
répondre aux besoins de santé et steve
est ce que le gouvernement fait de
nouvelles annonces pas de nouvelle
annonce hier au sénat où c'est le
gouvernement a déjà annoncé ces
dernières heures l'encadrement des prix
pour les gels hydroalcooliques il
affirmé qu'un report des municipales
n'était pas à l'ordre du jour il en fort
de la réquisition des masques de
protection ces masses qui olivier
ferrand l'a rappelé hier lors du débat
dans l'hémicycle ne sont pas utiles pour
la population au quotidien il n'existe à
cette heure toujours aucune
recommandation nationale ou
internationale sur le port du masque
pour lutter contre la propagation du
corona virus oriane merci beaucoup aussi
fort ce compte rendu du débat ciblera pc
votre commission et rené paul savary qui
attendaient ce débat est ce que vous
avez les explications vous attendez tout
à fait nous avions déjà organisé un
débat avec des grands responsables
les professeurs de médecine concernées
il y a deux jours et qui nous avait
donné un certain nombre de précisions
j'aurais simplement rappeler que c'est
un virus relativement
contagieux un contagieuse c'est à dire
que quand une personne en rencontres
doté bas 3 à 4 personnes peuvent être
touchées donc c'est contagieux plus que
d'autre virus est moins que d'autres et
également et que par contre il est moins
pathogène que d'autres transmission
virale ça veut dire que quand les gens
sont touchés
la maladie est moins grave mais il ya
toujours les personnes fragiles qui sont
touchés je pense qu'il faut que nos
concitoyens prennent conscience qu'il ya
des mesures de précaution à prendre je
les dis mais également que contiennent
les épis de minimes grippe plus les
personnes sont vaccinées moins la
maladie se transmet donc on voit que on
peut rompre la chaîne de transmission
par des mesures comportementale
individuel par des mesures de
vaccination quand c'est faisable et par
des mesures publiques pour éviter
effectivement la transmission du vide et
justement ces mesures publiques prises
par le gouvernement est ce que pour vous
ce sont les bonnes je pense que le
gouvernement a pris des mesures qui
étaient à la hauteur des enjeux faut pas
trop en faire faux pas qui était faux
pas confiné non plus tout le monde
faut pas que le pays s'arrête le virus
ne s'arrête pas non plus aux frontières
donc on voit bien que il faut que chacun
garde eu raison et prenne ses
responsabilités beaucoup de français se
posent la question de prendre des
mesures dans les transports c'est vrai
que notamment ces vrais france les gens
sont très proches dans les transports
bah écoutez on n'a pas l'habitude de
porter des masques il ya des pays
notamment les pays asiatiques ou aux
comptes ya le moindre rhume
voilà où un petit peu de tout avec qui
coule un enfant malade on prend les
mesures
chez nous tout le monde continue à
serrer les mains serrées dans le métro
un exter donc c'est vrai qu'on pourra
avoir des comportements différents messi
mais pour vous d kalck individuel il
faut pas prendre le public doit être
arrêté tous les transports ça devient
inconcevable en plus vous confiner les
gens vous vous êtes qui peuvent plus se
déplacer on entraîne une crise
économique des arrières qui n'est pas
forcément justifié donc faut garder
raison mais moins il ya de promiscuité
mois le virus se transmet ces logiques
l'autre question c'est celle des
rassemblements sportifs à on a vu des
voisins prendre des mesures le match
honnête foot en suisse est touchée celui
en italie aussi les matches se joueront
à huis clos au moins pendant le mois de
mars est ce qu'en france il faut prendre
des mesures pour les rassemblements
sportifs
ça dépendra si vous êtes dans des
endroits les équipements j'ai un peu
pâle en général a même lancé dans un
endroit où deux équipes se rendent
compte qu'ils viennent de deux foyers de
vie différent je dirais de foyers virale
éventuellement différencie ces deux
équipes sont pas du tout en contact ou
il ya pas de foyer il n'y a pas
forcément lieu de supprimer clos avec
des stades voilà il faut éviter quand
même la promiscuité au maximum donc
c'est aux gens aussi prendre la
responsabilité
on les oblige pas à aller voir un match
de foot celui qui préfère rester chez
lui à regarder dans la télé est un
comportement qu'on peut qualifier de
responsables la ligue éventuellement
qu'ils n'aillent pas au stade à l'autre
question c'est celle des écoles en
italie a annoncé hier qu'elle fermait
ses épaules au moins jusqu'à mi mars
est-ce que est la raison est ce que ça
va trop loin ce qu'il faut prendre ce
type de mesure en france notamment dans
les foyers de contamination il faudra
peut-être le prendre dans des foyers de
contamination de façon sporadique et non
pas de façon globale il faut pas fermer
toutes les écoles de france mais il ya
certains lieux où il faudra faire
attention fiery ta ble ment il ya des
grappes de foyers sont là voilà bien
spécifiques en fonction de ces
territoires
l'autre question c'est l'impact sur les
municipales on est maintenant à dix
jours du premier tour est ce que pour
vous il va avoir un impact notamment en
termes de participation à ce scrutin
by peu il peut c'est là qu'il faut que
notre rôle politique et de rassurer la
population faut faire cet acte citoyen
pourtant avec les précautions
nécessaires ne pas les serrer la main
quand on va quand on va au bureau de
vote et c'est que les personnes fragiles
prennent des procurations ça s'anticipe
pour éviter qu'il ya effectivement trop
de monde au même moment donc on peut
anticiper les procurations pour nos
personnes fragiles etc
et puis peut-être protéger ceux qui vont
tenir les bureaux de vote mais il n'y a
pas eu de dispute un pan non il n'y a
pas une promiscuité redoutable au moment
des élections municipales même s'il ya
des queues mais on va bien chercher son
pain donc on va continuer à aller
s'alimenter sortir dans la rue etc
les mesures prises par l'elysée du gel
hydroalcoolique des masques dans les
voilà ce sont des mesures qui sont tout
à fait me semble-t-il justifié et
justifiable se pose la question de
l'hôpital public à l'hôpital public en
crise depuis plusieurs mois maintenant
est-ce qu'il est armé aussi bien en
termes de moyens qu'en termes de
personnel pour faire face à une épidémie
si celle ci prend de l'ampleur
bah écoutez on a un excellent système en
france la fois de la médecine libérale
et puis médecine hospitalière on le sait
mais il manque de moyens bon il manque
de moyens en temps normal donc en
période épidémique
c'est encore plus cruciale ce manque de
moyens la gestion forcément forcément et
puis et puis c'est là qu'il faut prendre
des mesures pour protéger le personnel
parce que c'est personnel est mal à
lille peut pas soigner pour l'instant la
no qu'effectivement il ya déjà une crise
au sein des hôpitaux
en ce qui concerne le nombre de
personnels soignants médicaux mais aussi
mais aussi paramédicaux ils ont un rôle
est tout à fait essentielle dans dans
les soins en france
il en manque en temps normal donc aux
périodes automatiquement en période
épidémique
il nous manque encore plus donc c'est
vrai que l'afer est compliqué le
gouvernement qui a mis en place des
hôpitaux de référence ce qu'on appelle
la région ces liens fff qui en a assez
selon vous est-ce que vous par exemple
dans le département de la marne y en a
moi je n'ai pas dans le département de
la marne c'est un département important
on a un chu chu grâce n'est pas n'est
pas l'hôpital de référence et atx chu de
nancy compte tenu du nombre de cas qui
lie actuellement je pense que c'est
suffisant mais ça s'aggrave il faudra
que chaque département est riche en
hôpital de rhev ci se développe pour
faire en sorte d'éviter les déplacements
etc ça pourra se justifier mais il
faudra un certain nombre également de
cas graves en france on est dans un
nombre de cas très limités et les cas
graves sont très très limités et donc ne
prenons pas non plus des mesures
insurmontable et surtout et qui serait
beaucoup trop lourd de conséquences par
rapport à la pathogénie du virus dans la
question sur ce sujet il y aura une
réunion entre plusieurs ministres et des
associations d'élus cet après midi en
toujours sur ce coronavirus est ce que
pour vous les élus locaux les
parlementaires sont suffisamment sociale
aux décisions qui sont prises il le faut
on ne gagnait jamais suffisamment jamais
mais il le faut tant sur le plan bien
sûr national que sur le plan local
le parlementaire a un rôle également il
est important qu'ils soient associés sur
le plan local puis pour qu'ils puissent
transmettre sur le plan national au
ministre au ministre pluriel concernés
les informations de chacun des
territoires tous les territoires doivent
être traités à la même enseigne que
soient les grandes villes et métropoles
où les territoires et pierre georget ça
peut être amélioré olivier ferrand a dit
hier dans l'hémicycle il y avait
certaines décisions locales qui
pouvaient manquer de clarté en comment
voulez tout à fait tout à fait je crois
que c'est bien qu'ils aient un cadre
national mais après une déclinaison
locale
on peut faire confiance à nos préfets il
y en a un par département c'est
important à la rs il n'a qu'une part
région connaît une grande région comme
moi le grand est c'est grand et c'est à
l'est 1 c'est très long comme région
c'est vrai que c'est peut-être là qu'on
voit que le processus de décision et
éloignés mais les antennes
voilà faut des antennes il faut des
décisions qui sont adaptées aux
problèmes des territoires pour rassurer
au plus près nos concitoyens allez on va
passer à un autre sujet d'actualité en
que vous connaissez bien dont vous vous
occupez également depuis longtemps c'est
la réforme des retraites ne peut le
savoir hier l'assemblée nationale a
rejeté la demande de commission denquête
faites par les socialistes qui voulait
faire une commission d' enquête sur
l'étude d'impact de la réforme est ce
que vous regrettez qu'elle n'ait pas
lieu à l'assemblée
écoutez
nous on le constate la cour d vous
comprenez cette décision de l'assemblée
nationale de ne pas donner suite à cette
demande de commission denquête c'est un
projet qui est mal partie au départ sur
des mauvaises bases dire aux gens que
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite et
62 ans
nous sommes le seul pays en europe comme
quelque chose qui va pas avec
l'espérance de vie qui augmente et le
rapport cotisants passionnés qui se
dégradent dire qu'on fera un régime
unique en supprimant l'ensemble des
régimes
certes spéciaux mais également
complémentaires nul pas en europe ça
existe donc c'est mal parti
et puis on voit bien que c'est une
réforme qui au départ est une réforme
sociétale systémique qu'ils étaient pris
en main par notamment matignon et bercy
et qui s'est transformé en même temps
une réforme paramétrique parce qu'au
départ il y avait pas d'histoire
d'argent et puis après il y avait des
histoires d'argent donc on mélange une
réforme paramétrique systémique une
confusion tels que ça engendrait un
débat confus l'a9 semblait nationale que
tout le monde a pu remarquer à revenir
sur le sur le débat et sur le fond de la
réforme et sur cette commission
d'enquêté ce que le sénat pour en créer
une sur l'étudiant une demande qui a été
faite je crois par par un groupe
politique parce que cet épi que j'ai
jamais vu ça ouvre une étude d'impact
aussi lacunaire comme dit le conseil
d'état sur un projet qui représente 320
milliards d'euros au point de vue
financier et qui touche l'ensemble de
nos populations toutes les générations
sont concernés donc c'est vrai que on
aimerait pour prendre des décisions
impacté davantage d'avoir les en tout
cas les conséquences de ce type de
réforme
en ce qui concerne bien sûr le
financement et en ce qui concerne les
répercussions économiques érigé à une
commission d' enquête sur cette étude
dans la moi je suis assez favorable à
avoir plus d'information j'ai beaucoup
de mal
en tant que rapporteur à obtenir des
informations de la part de l'état on a
l'impression que l'on nous cache un
certain nombre de choses et ça c'est
grave parce que quand les gens ont
l'impression qu'on leur cache quelque
chose à on n'agit pas tout à fait dans
la confiance
or il faut redonner confiance à nos
concitoyens ce n'est pas en s'y prenant
comme ça qu'on leur donnera confiance
ce n'est pas en prenant des mesures
autoritaires qu'on imposera la loi de
manière volontaire se cache parce que
finalement le gouvernement n'a pas
toutes les informations
ouais voilà je sais peut-être sam
par exemple il n'a pas toutes les
informations présentes une loi pour
lesquelles les parlementaires n'ont pas
toutes les informations
parallèlement sont les partenaires
sociaux qui discutent sur le financement
du système
mais attendez dans quel monde vit-on
nous au sénat je peux vous dire on va
essayer de remettre les choses à
l'endroit et lire la vérité aux français
essayer de leur redonner confiance dans
leur système de retraites justement au
sénat où le texte doit arriver le 20
avril mais gérard larcher demande un
report de deux semaines seulement pour
laisser le temps à la conférence de
financement justement de produire ses
conclusions le premier ministre a
entrouvert la porte hier aux questions
d'actualité au gouvernement est ce que
vous êtes optimiste sur ce report de
deux semaines
on verra le résultat paraît tout à fait
normal de décaler de deux semaines
pourquoi pour prendre nos décisions faut
qu'ils aient des propositions de
financement de retour à l'équilibré
d'ici 2025 2027
le système universel par points tels que
proposés ne peut pas tenir si on part
pas d'un point zéro d' équilibre on peut
pas partir avec un déficit qu'on va
porter tout au fil des années la réforme
va coûter cher si on part déjà avec un
déficit
elle va coûter très très cher c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut être si
jamais vous n'avez pas ces informations
au début du texte si le gouvernement
n'accepte pas ce report qu'est ce que va
faire le sénat qu'est ce que vous allez
faire est ce que vous allez refusé
d'examiner le texte quelle est votre
attitude on en tirera les conséquences
qu'elles seront elles les conséquences
vous le saurez le moment venu mais elle
toujours est il que ce n'est pas
l'habitude de senna de ne pas regarder
les textes l'habitude de senna du sénat
c'est de se plonger dans les textes de
façon très approfondie pour amener un
complément à l'assemblée nationale c'est
ce qui justifie deux chambres
parlementaires dans les grandes
démocraties et le sénat et le
contre-pouvoir tout à fait essentielle
dans les événements que nous vivons
aujourd'hui et nous jouerons ce rôle de
contre-pouvoir donc il y aura un débat
le 20 avril si jamais il n'y a pas de
report du calendrier
il y aura forcément un débat mais pas
forcément vers riyad vous le disais pas
d'obstruction parlementaire le débat
s'annonce au sénat est-ce qu'il vous
faudra plus que les deux semaines
prévues est ce que vous demandez plus
déjà dans le calendrier
humour je crois qu deux semaines on peut
voir si on
plus de temps mais vous savez où siègent
jour et nuit et on pourra siéger le
week-end si besoin on va affronter cela
avec beaucoup de sérénité
je pense qu'il peut y avoir des milliers
d'amendements effectivement mais des
amendements de fond ce n'est pas
l'attitude du sénat de faire de
l'obstruction l'attitude du sénat est
véritablement travailler les textes au
fond et je suis persuadé que l'ensemble
des sénateurs sera très attachés parce
que il en va quand même de leur
responsabilité c'est une réforme
sociétale et qui pose trop de
difficultés pour quoi que ce soit
acceptable dans dans l'état actuel des
choses et on sent bien que pour faire
passer ce type de réforme fin des
adhésions il n'y a pas d'adhésion c'est
quand même une wii on nous propose une
réforme plus juste plus équitable
personnes adhèrent et quelque chose qui
va pas un mot sur la conférence de
financement que la cgt et force ouvrière
ont quittés si jamais elle échoue cette
conférence de financement et de leur
fille n'est pas dit il reprendra la main
sauf que si elle instaure un hdmi pour
un âge pivot vous le soutiendrez mais
nous verrons ce qui sera proposé
nous avons nos idées nous devons dire la
vérité aux français et la vérité sur ce
qui s'est effectivement que il ya un
problème d'âge qu'il faut véritablement
réglé parce que derrière si vous ne
réglez pas le problème d'âge ça veut
dire que vous baisser les pensions
on sait que nous sommes dans un pays où
on a des jeunes dépenses publiques on
peut pas augmenter les cotisations
on perdrait d'ailleurs des emplois donc
de la richesse donc en déséquilibre le
système donc si on baisse les pensions
on baisse le dîner au vieux de le niveau
de vie de retraité ça va pas aussi sur
le plan économique doc il faut prendre
nos responsabilités et faire en sorte de
reporter si on veut donner confiance à
nos jeunes faut leur dire la vérité et
voir comment on pourra à travers les
réserves à travers un système de
financement donner des garanties
puissance d' équilibre du système
nous les avons pas aujourd'hui un
dernier mot vous avez fait un rapport
sur l'emploi des seniors 1 vous rappeler
à ce chiffre 44% des français ne
travaille plus au delà de 55 ans est-ce
qu'il faut pas d'abord régler ce
problème avant de repousser l'âge de
départ
mais bien sûr et un certain nombre de
problèmes à régler tant qu'on n'a pas
réglé l'envol l'emploi des seniors
la retraite progressive le cumul
emploi-retraite avoir un autre oeil que
ce que l'on a aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des
seniors
les maîtres surtout pas dehors parce que
quand un senior perdu son emploi il
n'arrive pas en retrouver donc il ya des
mesures novatrices apprend quand on aura
pris ces mesures novatrices
quand on aura dit la vérité aux français
qu'on aura rééquilibrer le système
il sera toujours temps de changer le
mode de calcul plus un mode de calcul
différent cette réforme
pour l'instant on sait comment ça se
passe ce qu'il faut dire aux français ce
qu'ils veulent savoir c'est à quel âge
et je pars leurs questions à calais je
pars avec quel montant voilà et ça
actuellement on est incapable de leur
dire dans le nouveau système
allez on suivra les débats au sénat fin
avril ou début mai on verra selon le
calendrier comme tous les jours
n'avaient pas le savary on va se rendre
dans une rédaction locale
aujourd'hui on va aller à lyon retrouvé
nos partenaires du progrès bonjour
philippe kohly labourdette merci d'être
avec nous ce matin responsable adjoint
desk central au progrès vous allez nous
parler des conséquences du corona virus
la foire de lyon qui était initialement
prévu vient d'être reporté les pros
moment reprogrammé mi mai mais cet effet
dû coronavirus c'est un coup de tonnerre
dans le ciel économique de la capitale
des gaules mais parce que c'est une
décision rarissime qu'a prise
l'organisateur j ai les vans à une
manifestation majeure qui existe depuis
1916 qui n'a été interrompue que pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale entre 1942
et 1945
donc c'est vraiment la première fois
qu'il ya un report pour ce genre de
cause
bon honnêtement les organisateurs
auraient pu jouer un peu avec le feu
c'est à dire limiter la jauge à 5000
personnes par hall d'exposition mais ils
ont ils sont reconnus c'était très
difficile de faire un décompte juste
qu'ils ont préféré se conformer à la
réglementation établie dans le cadre de
cette épidémie
quel est le poids économique de cette
manifestation
on parle là d'un enjeu à plus de 200
millions d'euros tout le montage des
stands qui était prévue la semaine
prochaine est purement annulé et il
serait pas réduit à néant
sur cette période le carnet de commandes
de dizaines d'entreprises que dans le
domaine de l'installation de l'intérim
de la communication pour limiter le
manque à gagner de la société et le
patron adapté l'économie de la métropole
lyonnaise qui est qu'il est très
dépendante de cette fois les équipes de
jvn j ai des vannes sont maintenant
devoir convaincre les 800 exposants qui
avait versé un acompte et les centaines
qui étaient encore pressenti de changer
leur programme
en participant aux nouvelles dates c'est
à dire du 16 au 24 mai faut savoir que
l'an dernier la foire de lyon a
accueilli près de 198 milles visiteurs
avec 900 exposants et aurait alors on
emploie le conditionnel parce que j
allais 26 ne communique pas les chiffres
officiellement mais aurait enregistré 14
milliards d'euros de retombées
économiques directes 16 millions de
manière indirecte et généré un chiffre
d'affaires de 80 millions d'euros
pendant la foi et du double après la
fois puisque bien sûr les exposants
bénéficie d' de ce qu'ils ont pu montrer
pendant cette fois dans les semaines qui
suivent les mois qui suivent et
justement il ya des conséquences pour
les exposants également s'avérer plonge
dans un grand embarras parce que
certains avaient engagé de gros moyens
c'est des foires qui coûte cher en
installation en stands etc et certains
sont un peu dans la compréhension par
rapport au fait que des matchs de foot
ou rugby sont maintenues alors que cette
manifestation est et est annulé a
remporté en tout cas et puis surtout ils
ont un programme de foires et
d'expositions déjà évoquées sont pas
sûrs de pouvoir revenir au mois de mai
globalement ils ont moins d'événements
qu'elle est d'époque donc sam était un
peu en cause le repos et c'est moins
d'événements depuis un certain temps
elle remet en cause un peu leur
rentabilité voir l'avenir de leur
structure commune à viry ce qui a des
conséquences sur la foire de lyon vous
en avez parlé qui a aussi des
conséquences sur les municipales
notamment à villeurbanne où un candidat
a opté pour un meeting virtuel du coffre
oui on avait connu d'autres hommes
politiques qui faisait des coupes des
meetings virtuels là c'est le député la
république en marche pour une aumône l
onel qui se présente sans étiquette aux
élections notre métropolitaine sur ces
conscription de villeurbanne qui a
décidé de remplacer son dernier meeting
la 1ère semaine de campagne avant le
premier tour par rassemble anglais
virtuel en raison de l'épidémie de virus
la date est pas encore tout à fait fixée
mais il y aura des robots téléprésence
pour verbaliser les questions des
internautes et à l'arrivée sa frappe un
meeting moins onéreux qu'un petit
traditionnelle et puis ça évitera aux
candidats de serre et les poignées de
main et il essaye de ne pas le faire en
ce moment mais parfois ils se sentent
obligés quand avec gens racistes et ses
recoins de lehman donc là cette fois ci
il n'y aura pas ce risque de
contamination
merci beaucoup
merci philippe d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin on va regarder la une du progrès
consacré aux à la défaite de l'olympique
lyonnais hier soir face au psg en demi
finale de la coupe de france défaite de
lyon 5 à 1 face au psg c'est trop dur
c'est le titre du progrès ce matin merci
d'avoir été avec nous on va continuer à
parler qu'on à virus et municipales mais
dans votre département
cette fois rené paul savary avec steve
qui revient et s'il dans l'actualité
dans la marne ce matin le coronavirus
avec un premier cas confirmé dans le
département ouais l'union qui
s'intéressent à ce premier cas dans
votre département il s'agit d'un homme
de 38 ans l'âge est important 38 ans
dont l'état de santé est jugé
préoccupant il est actuellement
hospitalisé au chu de nancy avec trois
patients qui sont originaires de l'aisne
coronavirus toujours un département de
la manne qui s'organisent pour protéger
les personnes âgées
oui dans l'union toujours gros plan en
effet sur la maison de retraite de
pargny-lès-reims dans cet établissement
la moyenne d'âge est de 86 ans une série
de mesures a été prise fixe
frictional des mains à l'heure des repas
poignées de porte et désinfecter quatre
fois par jour
la directrice elle va même plus loin
puisqu'elle n'est skull pas un filtrage
des visites voire une fermeture complète
de l'établissement en fonction de
l'évolution du virus oriane un mot
rapidement l'inquiétude elle est là
aussi à danser et fade saison de
retraite tout à fait c'est là où il peut
y avoir des foyers qui se développent et
avec des conséquences graves c'est pour
ça qu'il faut prendre des mesures de
précaution
mais les premiers mesure quelle que soit
la période que les gens qui viennent
voir leurs personnes âgées se vaccinent
contre la grippe et que l'on met comme
j'avais fait et quelques années des
poignets en cuivre qui est naturellement
évite la contamination et la
transmission des virus et des bactéries
ce sont des mesures qu'on devrait
généraliser et qui limiterait les
propagation virale et on parle des
municipales n'essaie pas l'avant avec un
sondage si l'on en croit les sondages en
tout cas arnaud robinet mer les
républicains depuis 2014 est en tête des
intentions de vote
55% des voix selon un sondage
rené paul savary elle est bonne cette
campagne d'arnaud robinet allait elle
est très bonne c'est un vrai
professionnel il a pris la dimension il
a pris les tops je connais arnaud depuis
longtemps j'ai beaucoup d'affection de
respect pour son action et pour ceux qui
fait c'est un homme très chaleureux qui
aime les gens et qui aime sa ville en
conséquence les gens le reconnaissent et
je ne suis pas du tout étonné des
résultats de ce sondage
eh bien merci beaucoup merci steve
l'information sur ce coronavirus on
vient de l'apprendre puisque la corse
était jusqu'à maintenant la seule région
métropolitaine et pas renié trois cas
désormais en corse trois cas confirmés à
l'hôpital d'ajaccio depuis cette nuit
selon les informations de france 3 corse
et personnes auraient participé au
rassemblement 2011 rassemblement
religieux ou plusieurs cas ont été
détectés merci beaucoup